hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to plague Inc evolved
now I've been playing it a lot and I've
been trying to get to the point where I
could beat it on mega brutal without any
inserted genes and apparently that is
nearly impossible my first run that I
recorded last time was actually the
closest I've ever come to beating it so
I went ahead and played a little bit so
that I can unlock some genes and then
I'll be able to do this on mega brutal
with attributed to genes so for this one
in particular I have a TP boost which
gives me more designated which gives me
more DNA at the beginning of the game I
have genetic mimic which means it's hard
cure aqua side for ship transmission
which is very important arid climates
need to be conquered and this is the
only one I've unlocked here so I've
actually already beaten it and I've let
dank memes infect the entire world so
with proud further ado I shall beat it
again but this isn't the focus of this
episode I'm gonna fast-forward through
this one then get to the virus which I
have not beaten so here we go this is to
prove I can and not faking it I've
actually tested out a lot of things to
see if the PC version is different from
the mobile version and I'm pretty sure
it is slightly different and there's
actually some benefits that I can have
from getting different countries to
start with but I'm gonna go with China
just because that's my go-to one and I
haven't I'm not original so why would I
try anything different I'm Lee enough
the thing that I found the most about
this is you need to be aggressive like
the gameplay rewards aggressive
playstyle
so you have to be very pushy on what you
do you have to push symptoms right away
you have to get people sick and I mean
it does a lot of people will play this
game and they'll play like oh I don't
want anyone to notice it right away but
you really can't deal with that so long
as it's not a very serious disease when
it's first discovered then it's you're
gonna be okay see it's got a tough
through it you gotta not suck it's
basically what I'm trying to say here
don't suck like me dankmemes gonna in
fact the whole world come on means I'm a
child of the Internet I can't live
without my dank memes I guess everyone's
gonna die from the dank memes but that
doesn't matter
ah there it is dank memes it appears to
be mostly harmless that's what everyone
thinks but then they crop up and get you
with their lulz in there
Lowell cats in there keyboard cats lots
of cats pretty much all cats call the
police these dank memes is out of
control
Wow you gotta get those those cure ones
you gotta get the cure ones because if
you don't there's gonna fail ya got
drugs fear slows gotta necrosis that's a
little early for necrosis little early
for necrosis well that's an expensive
one if any of them shut down their
borders I'm kind of rubber nuked but
hopefully I'm just gonna risk it you
know what what's the worst that could
happen what's the worst that could
happen oh god no no oh God Iceland close
its borders I'm boned they're not
infected god damn it
there's still a chance with a plane
coming in there but it's very low damnit
necrosis
you just had to evolve on me why why
have you betrayed me why have you
betrayed me yes Iceland just got got Oh
is that everyone oh I think we're gonna
be good I think we're gonna be a-okay
maybe just maybe I need cold and I need
heat because those African countries are
gonna be the son of a [ __ ] in my back
what Africa cannot withstand my dank
means US president has taken ill from
dankmemes
Wow one of
a lot more people are dead than I
thought there were oh I'm good
oh I'm good I'm golden I'm a golden
child I'm good I don't need any help I'm
actually doing fine [ __ ] it I'll get
back to your own resistance cuz I don't
care Yolo or what-have-you
that's what these dank memes are all
about yeah I'm on a wind come on I did
it I did da dun did I'm I killed
everyone yeah go me go no healthy people
left well is this time to murder I
suppose dank memes to eradicate humans
damn we always knew that it would come
to that oh well can't beat him join him
whatever oh hey how's it going da da
I beat everyone with my dank memes can't
stop me alright so that was just to
prove that I could do it you know I
didn't cheat or nothin I am actually
good at this game probably you could see
that from the first episode that I put
out but now I'm gonna try virus on mega
brutal now viruses are different because
viruses are all about evolving very
quickly so you want your virus to be
able to mutate in very specific ways
that's why you need base oxidation so
that commute eight transmissions was
just actually very important because if
it was just mutating all the all the
symptoms
it would mutate them to quickly get too
severe too quickly then you'd have to
worry about that so with that being said
I am going to have pretty much the same
thing oh cos to devolve don't increase
that doesn't really matter to me none of
that matters to me because I'm not
actually gonna do Volf anything what I
am gonna play on mega Bruhl and I'm not
gonna call it jambalaya because that was
a temporary name that I put before booth
but oh no the whole world's got a bad
case of boof but ah damn it
who the [ __ ] the boof but it would be
the thing that undoes every nevermind
alright so I'm actually gonna do
something different just because I want
to cuz just starting with China would be
boring and somehow offensive so I
apologized all my Chinese fans and I
apologize now to all my UK fans because
I'm about to infect the UK sorry
yamimash and jacksepticeye
but begins in the UK um yeah first thing
with viruses you need to get the mutagen
up like the ability to mutate is
paramount of everything for a virus so
it has these special things called viral
instability that caused it to mutate
randomly and more frequently which is
what you really want now the reason why
I didn't get Darwinism which causes you
to meet a more often is because I need
to be able to mutate transmissions which
is super important and the good thing
about starting in the UK for especially
for a viruses that it takes longer for
something to get traction in the UK so
you can have it evolves more things and
if it involves more transmission things
and not just the symptoms like it's not
supposed to be doing but it's doing it
anyway then I'll be in good place
oh no airplanes use sterilization it's
about damn time I hope they do first
paranoia
doctor doctor I think I got boof but
look at my butt sir I don't think we
look at my butt that is evolving up a
very specific chain that's almost too
severe at this point Lake it's not
supposed to be that severe
I didn't oh I didn't even get the last
mutagen I'm an idiot I'm not gonna win
this mi I'm a dum-dum come on
mutate transmission now god damn it
spotted already at 1,000 people infected
I've been spotted this is [ __ ] booth
but was supposed to be way better than
this this is [ __ ]
I guess I guess when in the grand scheme
of things it's kind of hard to hide a
bad case of booth but people know people
tell Hooten you've got booth but doctor
my husband has booth but all over his
face he's got booth face on his butt
booth butt face he's got I'm funny here
we go it started but it's very serious
booth buts a very serious disease needs
to be cured the whole world unites to
stop booth but singing songs around
campfires to stop the horrible spread of
this horribly debilitating disease
but I I never claimed booth but to be
very smart so I guess I can't exactly
complain it's everything except what I
need why is it such a dick okay so now
let's see how we doing oh good
everyone's been infected start start
that does start II start let's get those
out of the white so we need we need
necrosis next we need to Krause this cuz
people have been dying pulmonary edema
that's close to necrosis why don't you
stop being such an [ __ ] everyone's
exactly everyone's infected but it's not
lethal so [ __ ] this right am i right
[ __ ] oh come on [ __ ] a whole
bunch of [ __ ] well I just got a
hundred and thirty DNA I don't know how
I don't care everyone's gonna die
whoa no healthy people left in the world
everybody is horribly afflicted with
booth but dankmemes and boof but have
conquered the world Oh booth but
mutation patterns extraordinary the
scientists is struggling to understand
the extraordinary mutation patters of
but move but to destroy humanity oh man
sneezing and diner here causing unwanted
accidents because of booth butts
Oh oops booth but done bad
I did it okay all right so there you go
I made it I did it with a virus I'm
really good at what I do I love this
game like I seriously play this game
whenever I have free time
whenever I just want to load up a game
on my phone and now on the computer I
just play for fun so it's great game if
you want to see more I'm probably gonna
play it a few more times just cuz I
really enjoy so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video don't play
this game beta everyone trust their
bodies applaud me everybody